from breitbart.com Kanye canceled by
Kanye walks out of Temple interview and
asks to defend ask to defend his
anti-semitism
I mean that is spicy but like here's
here's the crazy thing about it I I was
like letting him speak about it I said
okay if that's me so some people are
like Tim you know you should you should
have just let him speak and you Tim only
want to talk about Trump because Trump's
a safe subject and he was scared about
being banned and I'm like we said okay
we're gonna talk about it right but let
him start talking about it see we also
weren't like defend your anti-semitism
it would have been a it would have been
a comfort it would have been a
conversation that that would have
exchanged different ideas there was
different ideas coming from different
points of view here that obviously would
have clashed the audience could have
decided which idea is better me and Tim
were sitting here with some of let's be
honest here some of the smartest most
intelligent most uh creative minds in
the entire political social industry and
we were ready to have a conversation we
were ready to challenge our beliefs
their beliefs and and to come up with a
discourse we came here for that
conversation the other side left and I
just feel like I don't get it though I
don't get it see that's what I think the
thing is like I think the accusation of
being anti-semitic is so radioactive
that it puts everyone involved on the
defensive both the people who want to
respond to the accusation and the people
who are levying the accusation and I can
only imagine in Connie's position that
you are in yay's position I am so sorry
yay uh that you are tense to be prepared
to respond to it because you're on the
you are on the defensive all the time oh
and I want to shout out hey Greg Greg
price you're wrong he says yay got up
and left the timcast studio less than 10
minutes into the show not true you
tweeted it at 8 25 bro the show go went
live at 7 59. yeah it's 26 minutes 25 on
the clock but uh it is what it is I
thought I thought we were going to have
that conversation and a member I thought
yeah I thought yay wanted to actually
like defend his position on it yeah if
you're gonna make some claims back it up
well and like what what would you have
liked to have heard from him like how
would you look my view on it is so like
we had Bannon on and Bannon knows that
if you question the 2020 election
YouTube gives you a strike but he also
knows I don't agree with him on it and
so he like it was funny because he like
he he knows and he looks over at Lydia
and he's like I can say that can I and
then he starts you know talking about
Donald Trump and fraud and stuff and I
was like dude now you brought up we're
gonna talk about it okay and Bannon
entertained the conversation of me
disagreeing with him bannon's a Savvy
smart guy
when uh we had I think the first time we
had him on and he and I argued about the
election I said Trump got anti-elected
because people assumed that Biden's
approval rating was his his uh the
enthusiasm for Biden was so low he
couldn't possibly win but somehow did
and I said but did you look at the polls
showing enthusiasm against trump it was
higher than enthusiasm for Trump
According to some pollsters and then
Bennett was like yeah I like that he was
anti-elected yeah interesting that's
that's that's that's very good how often
do you have a guest on Whose views are
difficult to talk about on YouTube
because I especially with all the
vaccine stuff I feel like we've had some
where it's just it's just hard to talk
about it like I remember we had the uh
Surgeon General on from Florida but but
he said everything he was a government
official but but you know yay had two
people in his Corner that are working
with him that are also how do I say this
uh
master debaters uh that that could talk
about these these uh subjects that have
been that have been 12 years old that
have been talking about these subjects
for years and of course are ready to
debate them so he had people in his
Corner that were here with him for him
ready to uh have his side there's three
against two when it came to this
conversation you guys had gotten like
more time to talk to Nick earn more time
to talk okay absolutely yeah I mean Milo
was really interesting when he was on
the show and some people have said it's
like one of the like some high profile
individuals reached out and said that
that was one of the best shows I've ever
seen it's really interesting to hear his
thoughts someone pointed out uh Robert
Spencer and Super Chat said Milo is
purposely making yay look bad because he
really wants Trump to win
do you think I don't understand that one
yeah I don't really think that's how he
operates um this like but I I sorry
interrupt I I thought
like with them getting Fuentes invited
to to the Trump dinner
that was like really bad for Trump right
he's getting like every Republican
coming out against him like they
seriously caused harm to Trump if Milo
wanted Revenge that was it definitely
this negated all of that yay came out
and said nope Trump didn't know who
fundus was Milo's the one who invited
him okay so Trump's in the clear now so
now I have no idea what their plan was
maybe just trolling fun notoriety
you know it might all get overshadowed
unfortunately all of that information
might get overshadowed who knows do you
think the yay campaign could meet the
filing requirements to run for president
like right now it's a hypothetical
there's nothing in documentation right
we don't have a paper trail of an a
formal campaign I I I'm I'm genuinely
confused by whatever it is they're
trying to accomplish to be completely
honest yeah just trolling or something
so what do you think's the best outcome
from this this this you know uh look if
you're if you're someone who disagrees
with their views I think they just
shoved their face into the mud
like I didn't yo come on
I've got people criticizing me saying I
didn't push back hard enough and I
shouldn't have let him say those things
and I'm like but
the framing that you're like the hero
that asked him to defend
she was a framing right I feel like
those things are true though we got not
even a quarter of the way through the
show right there wasn't enough at least
give Tim a chance yeah let's let some
report develop we'll have uh I mean they
tried to do just that in the pre-show
but it didn't work I'm sorry sir we did
in fact get the recorder my my fault
officially if this is real life man yeah
yeah yeah I don't I don't like people
who blame their problems on groups of
people
like when Occupy Wall Street did it with
the one percent I said I mentioned this
earlier like you've got wealthy
individuals backing you uh you've got
obviously people who blame Jewish people
if you've got people who blame white
people and I'm like man stop blaming
everybody else for your problem and roll
up your sleeves and chop some Lumber
work hard I get it you know I was
mentioning this earlier I talked to it I
was talking to a woke dude years ago and
he said people don't understand what
it's like growing up being like a brown
skin like Hispanic dude in this country
where all the Billboards and everything
are white people every move you see is
white people who am I supposed to look
up to so we look up to people in other
countries we look to people who look
like us and my response was I think it's
unfortunate that you need that you see
race as a thing you need is a
requirement for what you need to look up
to
but I do understand you have a family
every day you see your dad you look up
to your dad he looks like you you look
like him but then you look at to what
this the country is promoting and none
of these people look anything like you
so I can I can certainly get that I I
hear I hear you but the reality is there
may be dominant groups in every country
in China it's so the white supremacy is
meaningless it's it's it's Chinese if
you're a weaker Muslim you're in serious
trouble it ain't the white people
oppressing you in the United States the
majority of the country is white and
Christian
but you can succeed and you can become a
billionaire
yay did it and then when he encounters
problems with it he decided the problem
was Jewish people I'm like I think it's
particular individuals who have it out
for you bro not not like bro the Jewish
people who work at this company have
literally nothing to do with yay's
troubles is that what he said like that
was how he ultimately viewed his
problems or yes because I I was like
what what are they they mentioned I said
what about Bezos what about you know
Shane Smith what about uh Elon and
they're like oh they all work for Jewish
people and I'm like what Bill Gates come
on man I'm sorry dude I can't buy that
advice is a great example I said this if
you really believe that I think this
might have been before the show I was
like how do you explain my show and he
said because God is on our side like
what dude like you can't say that if
someone is against me it's a specific
group of people and if we're winning
it's because God is here with us either
you as an individual regardless of race
gender orientation identity can succeed
or you think everyone is underneath the
boot of some group of people
so what role do you think I did hearing
thinking has on the American public
because I do think the points about like
we isolate uh certain racial votes we
use them as blocks to win identity
politics and identitarianism aren't
necessarily the same they overlap
identitarianism is government based on
identity so or or you know so I I should
be careful about how I say that I should
probably try to clarify better if you
think that
you are inhibited in any way or or I
should say if you believe it is
impossible because of your identity then
you are is a disservice like you are
being lied to there are uh
there are people I know from the
Philippines who may who who are
wealthier actually I think it's like
Filipino immigrants make like 90k to 120
can average in the United States it is
it is it's not the rights of the
individual it is their perseverance
their willingness to work really really
hard I think the problem with
identitarianism or uh identity grievance
politics is that you start to believe
you can't succeed because of immutable
characteristics seek to blame another
group of people and then you get chaos
violence and that's what we see with you
know from occupy to the antifa to the
BLM stuff black lives matter going on
protesting calling white or calling
black people white supremacists some
like you see you see where the ideology
is bankrupt
so you get kind of someone who's Owens
who's a black woman who has conservative
opinions and they call her a white
supremacist it's like okay your
race-based politics are bankrupt that
makes no sense to me they claim that
Luke being polish is a person of color
and we joke about all the time because
Luke is a white blue blue-eyed
blonde-haired man hey my people's
struggles are real uh but but there's a
problem with generalizations there's
always exceptions to the rules and I
think when you speak in over
generalizations whether you're blaming
one particular race or all particular
white men for your problems you're just
being intellectually lazy
um I I think there there could be a real
discussion to be had on a lot of very
powerful people on a lot of very bad
people but once you just start making
lazy generalizations you do you you hurt
yourself and you hurt the major claims
that you're making because you're also
going after innocent people you're out
you're also going after people who have
nothing to do with your ills or your
problems you're going after people who
of course aren't the source of your
problems
pointing fingers and you're just hold on
and you're just pointing fingers at them
which is not fair Mary's gonna walk out
needed to occur because I don't
necessarily think that he is just making
lazy generalizations to blame a group of
people for his problems his problems are
not ordinary problems that Ordinary
People face and to the extent that we
still operate on a meritocratic system
that is how Kanye became the success
story that he is but I think that he's
trying to point out ways that his
success is now being used against him
and he feels like he's being used as an
instrument or a cog in it much larger
machine he doesn't know what to call it
maybe or
he's not imputing it for the right
reasons but that machine does need to be
investigated and talked about it that
didn't happen tonight and that's what's
so unfortunate about it there was just
like
there was too much miscommunication here
for that to happen he said at the
beginning of the interview it's like I'm
I'm not allowed like they can lump
together the black vote but I can't lump
together this group's Vote or what you
know something that I said I'm
paraphrasing here and I find that
interesting I do think that we
feel I've always believed that Americans
are extremely uncomfortable talking
about race and that makes it almost
impossible to make any progress on that
front because you are so afraid of
saying the wrong thing and that's what I
think would have been maybe the best
outcome of this conversation is to get
someone else's perspective who right now
is willing to take a huge risk I
oh I know what you're saying like
definitely there are people who are
willing to blame their problems on you
know everything's out to get me this is
by you know this is the system is is
rooted for me to fail but I also think
that there are uh I think the way we
view race has creeped so much into our
government that we do have systems that
specifically are designed to lift people
up and unfortunately can make the
playing field on level and hurt some
groups of people I don't think that
we're able to fundamentally unpack how
we view race in this culture because
it's become kind of a left-wing taboo
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time